my wife Margaret has asked at what point
did you decide that religious dogma was
becoming a serious threat to science
education well I didn't realize this but
when I discovered that the Alexander
schools in Britain were being ninety
percent funded by the state about my
taxes are taxes and ten percent by some
millionaire religious millionaire and
that they were teaching their teeth they
were teaching that Darwinian evolution
was not correct and creationism was was
correcting them things like intelligent
design that the earth was four and a
half thousand years old that was the
moment when I realized that religious
education is not a good thing well I'm
an atheist and I believe in the secular
state I've often said my for religions
are atheism humanism Amnesty
International ISM and humor ism in
reverse order and I think that children
should not be taught religion or even
history nationalistic things until much
later so when they are old enough that
they have think for themselves and don't
have to put their trust in adults who
may have a vested interest in their
accepting things without evidence and I
think this is dangerous I obviously I'm
fully aware of the value to in some
people that religion has and its
involvement in ethical issues although I
don't think they're necessary and
certainly not for me and many other
people but that was the moment probably
about ten ten years ago or so and I I
think I'm a Jefferson sort of person
that
the you should have a separation of
church and state that not only
safeguards the secular enlightenment but
also safeguards religion individual
religions and so Jefferson was aware of
that and it's not only church and state
but also education schools of all kinds
they should not be sort of run by dogma
I mean for me science is about truth
science is the only philosophical
construct on which we can rely to
determine what is actually correct or
true otherwise you have to accept the
belief and accept individuals and I
think that's an educational issue
let's--oh tcas children should be taught
the very very strict rules of how to
determine truth and of course when you
do that religious religion falls falls
down on that basis that it can't be
trick it obviously can't be true because
there's no evidence and without evidence
anything goes and that's why they're
hundreds of religions or have been and
although some are more powerful than
others